>> Bill: SO, FOX NEWS ALERT
NOW, WERE TRACKING THE STORY,
ACTING SECRETARY OF THE
U.S. NAVY OFFERING TO RESIGN
EARLIER TODAY AFTER HE FIRED THE
COMMANDER OF THE AIRCRAFT
CARRIER.
THE USS F THEATER ROOSEVELT, THE
COMMANDER HAD SOUNDED THE LEARN
ABOUT A COVID-19 OUTBREAK ON
BOARD HIS SHIP.
LUCAS TOMLIN TRACKING THE STORY
FROM THE PENTAGON, LUCAS, HOW
ARE WE TYING THIS TOGETHER AT
THE MOMENT?
>> BILL, GOOD AFTERNOON, MOMENTS
AGO I LEARNED THAT NOT ONLY DID
ACTING MAYBURY SECRETARY THOMAS
MODLY OFFERED TO RESIGN, HE HAS
RESIGNED, HE’S TOLD HIS STAFF.
JUST A WEEK AGO, HE CALLED HIS
CAPTAIN BRETT CROZIER,
COMMANDING OFFICER OF USS
THEODOREE ROOSEVELT WAS ON THE
HOT SEAT AFTER WE HAVE HELP WAS
LEAKED TO LOCAL NEWSPAPER IN
SAN FRANCISCO, LEADING TO HIS
OUSTER ON THURSDAY BY THE ACTING
NAVY SECRETARY.
BUT WITHIN DAYS, THE ACTING NAVY
SECRETARY HIMSELF WAS PUT ON THE
HOT SEAT.
THOMAS MODLY VISITED THE
AIRCRAFT CARRY HIMSELF ON
MONDAY, FLYING HALFWAY ACROSS
THE WORLD TO GUAM IN THE WESTERN
PACIFIC WHERE HE ADDRESSED THE
KURU OVER THE LOUDSPEAKER THE GO
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE SHIP AND
ADDRESSED ALL 5,000 MEMBERS OF
THE CREW WHERE HE OFFERED TO
RESIGN, BUT WITHIN DAYS, HE
REALIZED HE HAD DONE THE WRONG
THING, HE APOLOGIZED, TODAY, HE
OFFERED HIS RESIGNATION, BILL?